supongamos que tenemos 100 focos voy a
poner los focos por aquí entonces déjame
dibujar pues no sé el primer foco luego
el segundo foco
y así sucesivamente hasta que llegó
hasta el foco número 100 este de aquí es
el foco número 100 y lo que voy a hacer
es prender los y apagarlos con ciertas
reglas pero antes de cualquier cosa
déjame decirte que todos estos focos
comienzan apagados entonces comienzan
apagados muy bien ahora lo siguiente que
voy a hacer es numerar los focos desde
el 1 hasta el 100 estoy aquí lo voy a
poner el foco 1 luego el foco 2 y voy a
seguir hasta el foco número 100
lo que voy a hacer ahora es hacer una
serie de pasos para aprenderlos y
apagarlos en el paso número 1 voy a
cambiar todos los focos que bueno ósea
para cambiar pues todos los focos va
entonces por ejemplo si hago estos pasos
como estaban apagados van a quedar todos
prendidos déjame escribirlo por algún
lado entonces en el paso número 1
entonces en el paso 1 todos quedan
prendidos prendido prendido prendido
todos estos van a quedar prendidos
excelente luego en el paso número 2 los
voy a aprender uno si uno no bueno más
bien uno no hay uno sí o sea que me
refiero con esto pues por ejemplo el
foco número uno no lo voy a cambiar
entonces estaba prendido se queda
prendido el 2 y entonces el uno se queda
prendido y el 2 se apaga el 3 va a
quedarse prendido el 4 se apaga y así
sucesivamente
entonces esencialmente cada foco que
tiene un número par pues queda apagado
en este paso el 100 también va a quedar
apagado
apagado muy bien en el siguiente paso a
ver déjame tachar esto de aquí en el
siguiente paso en el 3 voy a cambiar 2
no y 15 entonces qué va a suceder los 2
primeros van a quedar en el mismo estado
prendido y apagado pero el tercero sí lo
voy a cambiar entonces este estaba
prendido y ahora queda apagado apagado
luego el cuarto y el quinto no cambian
queda apagado el quinto a ver estaba
estaba aquí lo teníamos prendido verdad
entonces abajo queda prendido todavía
pero luego el sexto en este caso estaba
apagado y lo voy a cambiar ha prendido
entonces voy a cambiar 2001 sí o sea
otra forma de decirlo es voy a fijarme
en los números de los focos y entonces
cada foco que tenga un múltiplo de 3 va
a ser cambiado si es un múltiplo de 3 y
de 2 ya lo hemos cambiado este dos veces
verdad bueno 3 por el paso 1 por el paso
2 y por el paso 3 entonces lo que voy a
hacer ahorita es 100 pasos es decir voy
a hacer el paso 1 el 2 el 13 4 y así
sucesivamente hasta el paso número
entonces imagínate que ya hicimos todo
ese lío de operaciones que aprendimos y
apagamos focos en el paso 3 cambiamos
los múltiplos de 3 en el 7 los múltiplos
de 7 y así pero mi pregunta es después
de 100 pasos entonces lo voy a poner
aquí después de 100 pasos o sea después
del paso 1 paso 2 y así hasta el paso
número 100 cuántos de estos focos van a
quedar prendidos va entonces cuántos de
los focos
quedan prendidos ok esta de ahí es la
pregunta del acertijo cómo le haces para
descubrir de estos 100 focos cuáles van
a quedar prendidos bueno ok para
aclararlo un poquito en el paso número
100 por ejemplo en el paso número 100 lo
que hacemos es cambiar todos aquellos
que tienen un múltiplo de 100 ok
entonces qué sucede pues únicamente
cambiamos este foco de acá el foco
número 100 y si estaba apagado se va a
prendido y de prendido se va apagado
estoy aquí lo puedes hacer sin una hoja
de cálculo ni nada sólo hay que
encontrar la idea correcta y se puede
hacer a mano muy fácilmente va bueno
entonces la pregunta es cuántos son y la
pregunta bonus es cuáles son si quieres
intentarlo es momento para detener el
vídeo ahorita y a partir de ahorita
cualquier cosa que diga va a ser parte
de la respuesta voy a empezar con
algunas sugerencias a ver vamos a
pensarlo primero por pasos osea que
sucede en cierto paso en el paso número
dijimos que cambiamos de estado todos
aquellos focos que tienen pues
un número que sea divisible entre 2
luego en el paso número 3 voy a cambiar
todos los focos que tienen un múltiplo
de 3 entonces en cada paso que es lo que
estoy haciendo o sea a ver si estoy en
paz
en el paso n dejame escribirlo por acá
arriba si esto es una buena sugerencia
en el paso número n
cuáles focos se cambian pues justo a los
múltiplos de n entonces déjame
escribirlo con otras palabras voy a
ponerlo como que n es un factor del foco
estoy volteando un poquito la
observación entonces cambia
si n es un factor
del número
en el foco
del número en el foco esto de aquí
simplemente es una forma sofisticada de
decidir no sé por ejemplo en el paso 17
voy a cambiar todos los múltiplos de 17
o bien sé que voy a cambiar el foco 51
porque 17 es un factor de 51 17 por 3 51
va entonces simplemente vamos a cambiar
un poco cuando uno de sus factores es el
paso en el que estamos entonces ahora
vamos a cambiar esta observación para
algo que nos ayude más vamos a fijarnos
en un foco en un foco en particular
digamos el foco pues el foco número 8 va
el foco número 8 entonces cuando vamos a
cambiar este pues claro en el paso 1 lo
vamos a cambiar aprendido luego en el
paso número 2 lo vamos a cambiar a
apagado
eso porque 2 divide a 8 en el paso 3
nada va a pasar y nada va a pasar porque
pues 3 no divide a 8 exactamente
ok en el paso 44 divide a 8 entonces lo
cambiamos aprendido y luego cuál es el
siguiente paso en el que cambiamos pues
el 8 vamos a apagarlo y se va a quedar
apagado entonces cada vez que uno de los
factores es el paso vamos a cambiar el
foco y pues como puedes ver para que un
foco quede prendido hasta el final su
número debe tener una cantidad impar de
factores eso está muy interesante déjame
escribirlo por aquí porque es una
observación clave entonces para que un
foco quede prendido debe de tener
cantidad impar de factores
muy bien ahora esta es una pregunta muy
interesante cuáles números tienen una
cantidad impar de factores de hecho esta
es una pregunta que nos deberían hacer
desde secundaria porque está muy
interesante es bonita es teoría de
números básica y pues no sé o sea es
algo como que te ayuda mucho a entender
matemáticas vamos a explorarla un
poquito vamos a empezar con el 1 el 1
tiene pues nada más un factor entonces
uno funciona porque tiene una cantidad y
un par de factores entonces es el foco
uno va a quedar prendido porque solo lo
cambiamos en el primer paso qué tal con
dos los factores de 2 son 1 y 2 son 2 de
ellos entonces va a aprender si luego a
apagarse entonces va a quedar apagado
con el 3 pasa algo similar 1 y 3 son sus
factores con el 4 sus factores son 1 2 y
luego 4 y mira 4 también funciona aquí
tenemos tres factores que es una
cantidad impar de factores
entonces el foco con el número 4 va a
quedarse aprendido lo aprendemos en el
paso 1 lo apagamos en el paso 2 y luego
lo prendemos en el paso 4 y luego ya no
le hacemos nada
sigamos con 5 tiene a 1 y 5 luego con el
6 tiene 123 y 6 tiene una cantidad para
entonces se queda apagado
71 y 78 ya lo hicimos en 1248 cantidad
para 99 sus factores son 13 y 9 mira
otra vez aquí tenemos una cantidad impar
de factores entonces 9 también va a ser
un foco que va a quedarse prendido que
el foco con el número 9 también va a
quedarse prendido ahora vamos a seguir
no sabes qué mejor vamos a ver si
podemos encontrar un patrón a ver del 1
al 4 el brinco es 3
luego el brinco de 49 es 5 entonces con
un poco de suerte pero a ver si el 5
verdad si entonces con un poco de suerte
el siguiente brinco va a ser de 7 o sea
como que van brincando en números
impares 97 es 16 vamos a ver si funciona
sus factores son 1
24 8 y 16 si funciona esto está muy
padre fíjate de 9 a 16 el brinco fue de
7 d de 4 a 9 el brinco fue 5 entonces
parece que tenemos un patrón pero hay
algo un poco más evidente o un poco más
interesante de 14 9 y 16 es decir entre
9 y 16 te aseguró que ninguno funciona
pero bueno qué sucede con estos números
qué pasa con el 14 9 y 16 porque tienen
una cantidad de importes factores pues
fíjate aquí en el 2 el 1 está emparejado
con el 21 por 12 2 en el 6 1 por 6 3 6 y
2 por 13 6 siempre hay una pareja pero
en estos números que indicamos aquí
siempre queda un huerfanito por ejemplo
el 1 con el 4 si es pareja pero el 2 ya
no tiene una pareja distinta porque 2
por 2 3 4 si nos vamos para acá con el 9
3 por 3 9 y con el 16 4 por 4 es 16 así
todos los números que van a quedar
perdidos son números cuadrados perfectos
ser cuadrados perfectos causa que tengan
una cantidad de imparte factor
entonces regresando a la pregunta
básicamente nos están preguntando
cuántos números cuadrados hay entre 1 y
100 muy bien entonces pues podríamos
enlistar los verdad podríamos decir pues
son 14 9 16 y así hasta 100 pero como
solo nos preguntan cuántos podemos
pensar en un argumento alternativo es
decir cuántos números elevados al
cuadrado quedan más chiquitos que 100
pues bien es igual a 10 al cuadrado
entonces sólo podemos elevar al cuadrado
del 1 al 10 para obtener un cuadrado
perfecto entonces pues sólo va a haber
10 números que funcionen un al cuadrado
2 al cuadrado y así hasta 10 al cuadrado
pero bueno si te confunda un poquito
puedes enlistar los el último va a ser
100 y aquí en medio vamos a poner los
otros 100 es 10 al cuadrado los otros
cuadrados son 1 al cuadrado 2 al
cuadrado 3 al cuadrado 4 al cuadrado
vamos a poner los 5 al cuadrado que es
luego 36 49 64 y 81 listo entonces estos
números son los que quedan en los focos
que hasta el final cuando hagamos todos
los pasos quedan encendidos
que te haya gustado